[Music]
trans people have very very scared
having to constantly fight to be VR I've
had abuse for what I do it's extremely
frightening gender has become a
battleground a man who's telling me that
he's a woman and that if I don't accept
that I'm a nuts issue so toxic violence
has erupted these radical feminists
they'd lost the plot
are by definition maybe we know that 80%
have it feels very violent back off it's
not your fight it's the fight for the
right to be a woman
[Music]
Elijah is visiting his sister in
Leicester too long creepy right yeah
where he grew up as a girl I just have
memories of you in your football kids in
the back garden yep
playing football and rolling around with
your best friend playing army and then I
went as David Beckham to the Millennium
yeah New Year's party now working as an
actor Elijah's show real showcases not
only his talent but mirrors some of his
own personal experiences you started to
change virtual physical makeup of your
body didn't air yeah it starts to go
into the gym more yeah and to be able to
build your muscles around your shoulders
and give you that more masculine care of
Angie nagging
Alijah finally transitions at the age of
24 when he did come out it was quite
glaringly obvious the next morning I
remember mum coming in bringing me a cup
of tea in the morning and then seeing on
the bed and she just start crying she
said it's just been so hard already and
we don't want it to be harder and and I
remember just being like but this is
better this is good you know
although Elijah lives as a man he hasn't
applied to legally change his gender
this is possible under the 2004 gender
recognition at but only after a series
of tests have been passed described by
many as onerous and humiliating is
estimated there are up to 500,000
transgender people in the UK our
research found in the last year 12,000
253 people were seen by NHS gender
identity clinics in England but only
4910 gender certificates have ever been
issued so the government's considering
simplifying the process allowing
self-identification when I was five
years old I realized that I wasn't like
other boys and
I started looking for girls clothes
I went to university as it man but at
night I would be sue sue Pasco has fully
transitioned and legally changed her
gender and for her it was a long and
arduous process for years she was
married with children when our first
child came along she didn't think that
sue should be in our lives and that it
wasn't right for the children and I
agreed to that and I went into an
internal prison in 2014 she finally
became sue traveling to India for
surgery when faced with a three-year
waiting list in the UK today I am at
peace and now I'm legally female so I
have a female birth certificate and I
would be buried as a female and if God
forbid I ever got into prison I would go
to a woman's prison feminists are
against moves to make the process sue
went through to legally change her
gender easier concerned
self-identification could be abused
compromising female only spaces and
eroding women's rights in North London a
group of women awaiting to make a splash
posing as men to invade the male only
female male they believe the idea of
self-identification the ability to take
a box to be seen as a woman in the eyes
of the law is ludicrous you know you're
baking a pie you have pursuing pawns
here you have swimming limbs you do the
swimming pools you have the sleeper
trains you have the youth hostel
Association you have curl guys all these
places say as soon as you say the magic
words I am a woman that's it you're a
woman and you can access women's spaces
this stunt was organized by Hannah Clark
we protest about bathrooms and we
protest about changing words but those
aren't the big deals are there it's it's
it's places where women are vulnerable
that are a big problem so prisons and
hospital wards and refuges are a massive
issue it's been in the news hasn't it
Ian Huntley could get a gender
recognition certificate and get a new
birth certificate become to all intents
and purposes a woman and be housed in
the female prisoner state if anyone can
be a woman what is to protect a woman in
a woman's space
[Music]
it actually feels quite painful to have
a group of people who are campaigning
against your participation in everyday
life we went to Manchester to meet Jess
Bradley
she says the objections to trans women
accessing female spaces just don't add
up
trans people disproportionately face
domestic violence and sexual assault we
need access to services we've had the
Equality Act for the last eight years
and that's actually the act that allows
trans women 20 women space it's a lot of
a long time for these abuse to take
place but they they happen the evidence
isn't there
it wasn't easy finding Jess most trans
people we approached were reluctant to
go on camera some scared of
repercussions others refusing to appear
on a program alongside the feminists
trans people are very very scared of
talking publicly about trans issues like
I know that simply by doing this piece
of media that I will be hounded on
social media actually a really hostile
time for trans people one of the things
about the gender recognition act debate
and consultation is a is it's kind of
given license to anti trans activists to
kind of spark a public debate about
trans identities and trans people in a
way that has felt a very violent
and there's hostility on both sides
these are trans activists protesting
outside a feminist meeting there
shouting turf it stands for trans
exclusionary radical feminists across
the country clashes are erupting between
the two groups so many problems in the
past when we've announced better news
ahead of time where trans rights
activists have found their venue over
and over again asking them to move no
platform us because they consider us a
hate group Hannah is at a meeting of
women who feel they've been excluded
from the discussion about changes to the
gender recognition Act one woman told us
how she'd been attacked by a trans
activist at another meeting who was
later found guilty of assault impact I
understand that gender dysphoria is a
very very serious and upsetting thing
but they cannot actually be women the
most play can be is what we call trans
women
[Music]
and there's more trouble at today's
event this time over lesbian rights
[Applause]
I don't think so generally I think most
people in the room are forward-thinking
people that are trying to get their head
around you know the nonsense in society
and this year's London pride protesters
also disrupted the parade claiming the
trans movement is anti lesbian
I'm absolutely shocked at the level of
vitriol the level of sciencing even
asking for the discussion is thought of
as transphobic dr. Heather Brandt's
klevens wrote a book on trans children
she's on her way to speak it's an event
where again she's met by opposition the
sit and perpetuate a hateful rhetoric no
one has the right to tell you how you
want or do not want to identify that is
up to you I haven't started any kind of
hormone therapy yet or a full transition
so what will happen to the gender
recognition act directly affects me we
weren't allowed to film inside this
meeting but back at her home Heather
describes the aggression she's faced
here a group of protesters are blocking
her way we need to get in today I don't
like being on a stairwell where I'm
frightened but I'm going to be pushed
down by a man with a balaclava and the
mask is telling me that he's a woman and
that if I don't accept that I'm a Nazi
it's extremely frightening it should be
possible to have a discussion whether a
range of different people with a range
of different truths who can enter into a
dialogue about this but what does the
public think according to the British
social attitudes survey people seem to
be pretty liberal with 84% claiming not
to be prejudiced at all against
transgender people and when asked if
most people who are transgender go
through the process because of a
superficial or temporary need only 12%
of women agreed and 18% of men 72
percent of women said they were
comfortable or very comfortable with a
transgender woman using a female public
toilet with 65% of
saying they were comfortable or very
comfortable this is a fire this is a
struggle for women's rights and it's an
urgent fight staunch feminists like dr.
Nicola Williams argue the public hasn't
been given enough information to fully
understand what's at stake we have to
find this courage to speak out by me
acknowledging that a trans woman has a
male body could be considered hate trans
women are by definition Mabel you know
they were born male you know I don't say
that to be offensive
you know it's fact I've got no problem
with trans people living in role as a
woman because gender dysphoria is real
there are times when biological sex does
matter for safeguarding for privacy and
dignity fairness in sports for example
and that's when the sex of purpose as a
person must be acknowledged in a society
we always have checks and balances we
have we so that people do not abuse the
system
the question of who decides who gets to
be a woman seems destined to become more
polarized the centuries-long fight for
women's rights engulfed by a whole new
conflict we must not confuse ideology
with biology being transgender is not an
illness I want to live in a world where
being trans if it is a choice I know I'm
not bigoted I know that people are going
to kill me that people are so so angry
and so against something that they just
don't understand we must have debate
about something that potentially affects
huge numbers of people
you